[Music]
all right what's up everybody welcome
back to careful boys we have with us a
very special guest today the ceo special
the ceo of the filipino american
also i'd like to i'd like to say this is
the guy that discovered the fountain of
youth and is shystally not sharing the
secret with any of us yeah dude please
welcome dante
[Applause]
and also
ryan's first day of being host
i know how we can go different places jk
news is turning filipino very slowly
yeah this is the filipino side of the
room right here this is called
diversification as best we can do it
yeah we're going to do a akumate later
on and see who who ends up it's like
blood
asian american one exactly blood sport
asian american style
i heard buccaneers
asian americans who comes out on top
early predictions japanese maybe
but if it's mma
dude
there's some gangsters there's some
gangsters cambodians out there that
don't give a [ __ ] yeah and they'll just
fight to the end or the mongolians that
wrestle and [ __ ]
oh
they're shooting arrows all the time but
what about like the shadow and soccer
fools look at those dudes
[ __ ] up bro
do we let someone sing because it was
simone we left someone that sounds like
that's a pacific islander someone's
probably yeah they got a different they
got a different bubble on a scantron
that's all i'm saying about this lawn
are they asian though are they
considered asian i don't know it's asian
pacific island because if they are asian
i'm [ __ ] pissed
that when we were getting beat up by
black people they didn't jump in they
should have
we need their help i i was straight tell
samoan straight up like i need help and
he's like
is there a hotline you're like you're
like a little one of us he's like y'all
filipino you're like a little one of us
i'm like exactly so help help a
[ __ ] you know i just want to
tell like little people huh no yeah
we're like the russian doll where if you
open simone there's no filipino guys
no there there was some like uh
basketball leagues we were playing where
younger the tiger league that they
didn't let filipinos play
why because they were like because
they're kind of really asian
because it was like chinese japanese
koreans and they're like y'all ain't
really asian who said that they're right
tigers
you want to go back like the
why is it that every asian club like you
go to a bar or whatever there's always a
polynesian bodyguard or like a [ __ ]
bouncer because he knows how to control
the situation and keep everyone in good
moods because they're big
but they're so big they're usually jolly
because they're too big because they're
nice guys no one's gonna mess with you
you can't be big and mean because then
you have no friends i feel like they
feel like they're just
dealing with a bunch of preschoolers
when they're guarding an asian club yeah
yeah they're just watching recess i got
into a fight at a bar in uh little tokyo
and all the uh guards are
simone women
was this that oywake up yeah yeah i knew
it how did it go i knew it because we
used to do the best there and it is all
simone women and they're [ __ ] big
yeah
and women yeah you look at them and
they're like oh she'll [ __ ] me up and
then when i broke out they were just
holding like dudes down like it was like
yeah like no problem dude it's great
because over there like you know when
you go to club as a dancer you hate this
and everyone goes anthony's here anthony
why don't you go dance and you're just
you hate him
when i was there those guards those
girls went up to me and they were like
how come you ain't dancing and i was
like right away i'll do anything you
want yeah
he's my old ass how come you ain't
dancing yeah dancers see you and they
something like there's a dancer
telepathy or something and they like oh
you walk by the circle they're like look
at you like are you gonna rap what you
doing i'm like
do i go mm-hmm do something right now
i'm not even one right pants my shit's
too tight right now i got boots on yeah
that's his origin story basically
every dancer had an origin story like
that where they got challenged and that
was like i'm gonna get challenged right
now
he knows i mean you you either gonna be
[ __ ] playing basketball singing or
dancing that's one of those we were just
talking about that why is that did you
start that too yeah i don't think the i
think we talked about this that's part
of it that's part of the culture
are the filipinos the latinos of asians
yes
kind of yeah but yeah definitely we are
everything that happened tomorrow are
you guys more like the blacks asia well
according to rampage came the blacks of
asia two away yeah rampage rampage
says that the vietnamese is the black
i'll give it to vietnamese definitely
yeah he says that the vietnamese he
doesn't date vietnamese girls because it
reminds him too much of himself and the
black community i'm half pillars to the
mexicans well his actual quotas
vietnamese are the n words of asians
yeah when did he say that on on rogan
was it on rogan or something like you
know brandon brendan shot yeah oh he
said that my little brother said that an
interview back in the 90s and we got so
much background oh
damn it was crazy wait what got backlash
like he was saying we're the black you
know we're like the black asians who
said that my brother said in an
interview for a magazine back in the 90s
but then i had to come back hey he's
just saying we like the asians of
assault and they're like oh yeah is it's
not a bad thing like the ones that are
getting mad they're like they're
associating negative truths because
you're gonna get mad at you now you say
other asian ain't got soul especially
like
filipino
a lot of just
let's be real they don't want to be
white like there's a there's a we're a
colonized country like spain yeah
america there's like there's a big
is there colorism in the philippines you
can go dude yeah
there's billboards where you can
right now there's billboards where you
can buy bleaching
i just don't see pacquiao doing
bleaching treatment that's why i don't
know oh have you seen his wife yeah his
wife is yeah she's a white palette she's
she really into that the lighter the
lighter she looks like a disposable
camera when the flash [ __ ] up
wow
you don't like any yeah that's a good
analogy it just gets all blown out
that's they say or so i was taught by my
philippine homies that you know it's
because if you got dark skin out there
you're a field worker so you're trying
to be pale so that you can show that
you're of higher class and stuff yeah is
it what if you are a film worker
you look like
you guys hate on them though like oh
you're just a light skinned yeah
i don't know it's like it's like i got
hated on for being dark skinned filipino
but like
do you think it's it's uh it's more on
women because like i know in japan
women want to be more like what but
there's actually a specific style where
they go to the tanning salon and they
want to be more tan but that's a
different like subculture but then the
dudes
i've never heard of like this whole
the dude's got to be light and pretty
you know what i mean like bulky boys
they're like
i mean i think it's changed hopefully
it's changed i think it's changing but
even when you go back to philippines you
see the filipino stars
they do not reflect
the average the average filipino yeah
not at all they call the average
filipino like not they like it's known
like the masa the masses and then the
stars are like mostly
mostly my 700 mostly the stars are like
half white half filipino people they all
look like alex wasabi
yeah
yeah alex wasabi is 100
so it is like i don't know because i'm
thinking about mexico and their soap
operas are like more spanish-looking
same thing yeah then you know but then
it's like something like that in the
philippines if you have more spanish
blood in you you are considered like wow
it's like when you watch bollywood
movies all any people are buff but then
you like actually look at everybody and
you're like
they're skinny
and you're right about it that's it that
this one's going on youtube right yeah
yeah this one's going what's this one
here too
people like to always point out whenever
i'm you look filipino yeah people always
go dang you're dark and they always say
it like that and i'm like why are you
guys saying like that who says that i'm
just random people whenever i get really
tan because i can get like i can get
really dark
why is dark a bad thing i don't know
you never go to the [ __ ] okay you
never go to the beach right and you and
then and then like i judge the [ __ ] out
of my girlfriend because i'm like man
you're gonna burn and get [ __ ] cancer
bro and then i see somebody with a tan
and i'm like
you don't need sunscreen
you get my fist bump
i think it's a leftover collar it's a
calling colonized mine we all have some
kind of colonizer
that we're still working through i would
love to be darker i i feel so can you
tell yeah but i gotta like be very
consistent luckily we're always indoors
here though the fluorescent lights and
there's no windows or breathable air
here what can you tan i can but it takes
a while like i got to be like like you
were in maui for a week you got one
shade darker you'd be like super dark do
your girls care if you were lighter or
darker because um my girlfriend says
that she likes me darker because i uh
because one of the two contrasts because
she's like she's like the color paper oh
she's whole like the color of paper and
then like it's just like and then she
thinks that dark is more masculine
because she goes light guys feel more
like soft soft and yeah dark and
handsome but like dark looks more like
rugged in the club you're gonna start a
fight you find that light scan dude and
you'll slap that dude first
that's true that's how you defuse the
situation uses it you're in a club
you'll see him first you're like you see
that dude something pop off you just hit
that guy and he starts crying
in terms of gradient
like uh like all the k-pop stars and
stuff like that all of them are
extremely like fair-skinned pale
leaguers
how many bts members do you think you
get beat up in one sitting like in one
like in one area i'm not gonna answer
that because there's too many people
love bts
but they look just young bts wow kids
choreographed loves bts
to me they don't they don't look like um
grown men they look like pretty boyish
dudes hey y'all today's video is brought
to you by babble
i know there's so many of you guys out
there that's like you know what it's a
new year
i got some other goals i've done the
weight loss thing i've cleaned my room
maybe i should learn a new language but
i don't know where to start because i
don't go to school anymore you should
check out babel because it's one of the
top language learning apps and it has
over 10 million subscribers
that's a lot but you know what whenever
i try to like learn languages and stuff
i'm like oh i don't got like two hours
to like sit there a class that's crazy
but you know what's awesome about babel
is they have 15 minute lessons that you
can just learn on the go and it makes it
super convenient i love their ai
technology and they use over a hundred
language experts
put it all together all imagine all the
smartest brains put it together so now
you can learn it in the best way
possible that's like you get all these
harvard professors on language
into your phone that's pretty awesome
it's very awesome and they also have the
speech recognition technology so that it
can help you with enunciation because
you know if you're just looking at
flashcards ain't nobody tell you you're
doing it wrong but this will help you
with enunciation and getting your accent
down just the right way so you could
speak like a local and what's really
cool is they have 14 different languages
to choose from and it's like maybe i
want to be like
french today or maybe i'm going to be
like german today i don't know but i
have many many choices at the fingertips
of my hands and the best best part they
got a 20-day money-back guarantee so
you're like you know what i'ma try this
out and see if i like it and if you
don't you get your money back
so if you want to learn a new language
it's one of your goals this year go to
babble.com
off the record that's babbel.com off the
record because they got a special deal
for our listeners you pay three months
and you get another three months for
free that's six months for the price of
three babble.com slash off the record
yeah but when we talk about like
effeminate we talk about older guys
right or like rugged dudes we don't
picture that at least or like at least
when i think about a picture of the rock
in asia like in asia i would think of uh
[ __ ] like what's his name on uh
last samurai
tom cruise
no like there's white ken watanabe or
like his his buddy that's in like
[ __ ] he's scorpio
yeah oh yeah he's in all the [ __ ] like
westworld or whatever he always plays
the same guy yeah the samurai yeah
number one samurai stoic samurai that's
all he plays yeah i guess it's down to
tape when i think of an older dude it's
the facial hair that's like more
masculine i think of that guy yeah yeah
i don't think of a j-pop star guys
oh yeah yeah i think i think a guy that
didn't [ __ ] shave and take a shower
for a week and he's darker
a homeless man squid games when he won
squid games he left he was depressed it
came back and he was bts like awesome
the red hair what you got the sun came
up
yeah
he was like growing up bts all of a
sudden or the grandpa
maybe the brighter hair made his skin
look darker oh cotton and that's what it
does right i mean skin tone it's weird
how we got it when you get kind of get
[ __ ] from your girls about like like you
gotta get too dark freshman year of high
school when i when i stunned in too much
and my [ __ ] got really light and it made
my skin look twice as dark and she said
please don't do that again damn i don't
know yeah we all did this because it
just made me look too dark and in a
circle of filipinos that's like hey man
that's why i think the chain reaction is
like i originally never had a problem
with anybody being dark until people
kept saying it to me and then you just
passed i got brothers like i'm the
lightest of my brothers oh you're the
ladies of my brother i'm like oh here's
the lighter one oh yeah that's true my
other brothers are darker yeah there's
one brother but they call he's the dark
one your brother's uh so do they resent
you for the field or how does that
yes yes
exclusively they got the outdoor chores
[Laughter]
they're doing the chicken fighting you
were dark when you were like neverland
and [ __ ] though yeah now it's dark
compared to white guys yeah for sure
but before i prepare the philippines
like are you a little lighter i mean i'm
not like super i'm not like
no yeah half white looking
damn yeah so usually growing up it's
like every filipino person like i was
afraid of going out in the sun they're
like don't for that reason yeah i'm
surprised you don't dress like an asian
mom with the [ __ ] things and a visor
a parasol jumpsuit dude 360 visor
no yeah i used to be really scared of it
because i was always afraid of that
remark that you're someone's gonna say
goddamn you got dark like they say it
like that all the time but it's all
relative right only asians are saying
that to you right nah it was it was
because when i went to high school and
passion was going up to you saying dang
you're dark bro yeah hell yeah i've
heard it from a black because
because i swam i swam and i played water
polo so i've been in the sun all the
time so you were done it was looking
hella dark i got real dark and now today
i still can get dark i can get dark
really quick like within like three days
afternoon i'll be dark as well yeah yeah
one day in the afternoon i'm dark one
week in hawaii bro i did a movie back
nick called faking the [ __ ] where i
played this asian kid adopted by a black
family with tata and ollie right but
then i have this brother who's black in
the movie and like we have this whole
fight in the film about skin tone and
with color and like it's because the
color of my skin we were doing this
thing and it's summer time we're
shooting [ __ ] and he's like damn dark
we're the same color
[Laughter]
we're talking about color this screen
we're the same damn color
the same shape fake of what needs to be
shown in schools bro that will bring the
communities together it's just loud it's
not politically correct there's a lot of
unpolitically correct jokes which is
great for you guys because that [ __ ] i'm
like you watching now it's so good you
ever seen that faking the phone oh my
god it has everybody that you like for
the 90s yeah first of all what yeah and
i play a an asian kid that's adopted by
a black family and i don't know i'm
asian i just think i'm black that's tiny
kung fu panda whoa
that's cool yeah margaret chose it too
but chose a chinese girl who's trying to
get into the black scene because she
just moved here from china so she's like
faking the funk but then i'm like her
counterpart that's like oh
but you're not faking the [ __ ] like
you're
i mean i guess you're kind of black i
mean you're asian but you're black
that's the time dude it's a dope oh man
go watch that movie go watch that movie
it's hard as hell to find too by the way
yeah i think it's i think someone just
bootlegged and uploaded on yeah but they
upload it into 30 times
yeah it's crazy like three minute parts
i watched the whole thing that way
you love that movie there's a playlist
that has
18 ads yeah i can tell you all of the
rates of expedia everything from all you
guys bro the movie was in for 30 parts i
swear to god but it was worth it it was
worth it it's one of them hood movies
back in the day where you could buy at
the liquor store
you know it's in that walmart that's
that's that walmart stack like what is
this it's super nostalgic it is for 10
bucks yeah i think you already swim
through them to find what you like ain't
not on dvd because i've only like seen
it on vh oh it hasn't do you have it
no i don't even have it and on i saw
someone selling it on ebay or some [ __ ]
for like 350 dollars for that vhs thing
whoa it's crazy expensive what i'm gonna
check it out it's one of those rare gems
man yeah definitely watch it
i've always felt
uh sorry for people with light skin
i thought you could say filipinos for a
second like in the military
yeah
all the white dudes like every hour
they're like yeah dude yo you could put
sunscreen on you you have to do it
because they're gonna hurry well you're
in the sun like all day long right like
you're really especially in the desert
you're really like in the wilderness
right i thought they wouldn't let you
use it no you have to they're getting
fried to death don't get they'll get
boils and [ __ ] like like they're out
we're out there for like special
military [ __ ] did they give you special
rations first [ __ ] coppertone
military grade
unblocked they don't have that they
don't got military that's the same thing
this is kind of [ __ ] up dude it's the
same end up in a [ __ ] like just
imagine the dude who's trying to like
[ __ ] change the budgeting breakdown
he's just like i know all this is going
to the weapons and stuff but if we could
just get one percent to the sunblock
category for skincare
and they just go nah
more more ammo loser
i didn't grow up using sunblock yeah me
neither you probably didn't need it no i
never did i just got [ __ ] dark older
i'd eat it now now i'm in like now that
hawaii is on that maui beach that's hot
it's something different now though is
it is it me or is it no the sun's
different guys don't blame the sun it's
the ozone layer dude you know
you know what is sad is like in high
school i remember some of the like the
chinese girls were saying that if you
just put sunblock on just indoors your
skin will get lighter you ever hear that
room no
they make it shut up all right yeah i
tried it
here i am
you do look fair
this is the lightest i could possibly
get this is absolutely snow wife's name
is white who because she's white the
fairest one of all snow white i mean
that's that's the thing it's it's in the
beauty standard i thought that was her
skin right just snow white that's what
that's what we're talking about her
ethnicity yeah that's why
oh yeah she's not watching snow white
porcelain
so catching up with you like what are
you in the middle of right now no i'm in
the middle of a tour right now i'm
touring my uh did my debut my
directorial debut the fabulous filipino
brothers
we're touring the country it drops
february 8th is it outdoor tour we get
dark or is it indoors
good question good question it's indoor
okay good it's gonna
been
thing because it's like every every time
we go to new theaters like a whole new
thing you got to deal with but
everyone's been people braving the
elements coming out because different
states have different rules yeah and we
went to canada too so obviously another
country was like what was that like way
more straight cool but someone had
kyokovic there
in the show not there no like we knew a
lot of the actors there that came and
then all of a sudden they hit us
afterwards like hey yeah like so-and-so
just tested positive and we're like
so we all testing day at five days in a
row like dude this dude what happened i
mean it's omnichrome it's everywhere so
we're we're already risking it but yeah
and we we've all probably came in
contact with a bunch of people like it's
only when you find out you definitely
came in contact with somebody like oh
[ __ ] stressed out but everyone's been
great and joe's in the movie yup this
guy's in it i didn't even know that was
it pleasant surprise yeah because i had
no clue i just went into blind and joe
kills it dude joe comes in and kills
that [ __ ] it's funny because a lot of
our uh it's already released in
southeast asia so a lot of our fans in
asia were screenshotting the scene and
sending it to me and they're like i'm
[ __ ] [ __ ] i can't believe it and i'm
like dude good easter egg in the movie i
know there's hella short
but kills it kill kills thank you nah i
mean you [ __ ] made it so fun dude it
was a good scene you took it to another
level so i i appreciate that i can't
wait for people to see it but the
response has been
amazing so far so
you got to screen it in vegas we did
screen in vegas
we did it
like a week ago right like yeah like
like three days ago four days ago how
come you can tell me i forget you're up
there reverse marketing were you upset
reverse market three days ago yeah [ __ ]
you should have came through it was fun
that was a good journey yeah returning
engagement for bart of course like a lot
of filipino communities like they miss
you then they try and get you coming can
you come back we're like
we just did a whole show
y'all gonna pay for the theater if you
pay for the theater let's go we'll come
back there's a [ __ ] there's there's like
three island pacific uh supermarkets
but the problem is again it's recovered
it just makes it a little bit like yeah
we're already like being risky like we
stopped doing after party like one after
party in san francisco we're like ooh i
don't want to be no in a [ __ ] club
with all these people
it's like
punching light skin fools
i hate when they split the club up by
color man this sucks
[Music]